évidemment le retour de la confrontation
c'est vraiment une [ __ ] comme par
hasard [ __ ] elle refuse la confronte
en plus
comme par hasard en fait c'était juste
pour lui casser les couilles je suis sûr
alors c'est un enregistrement choc on
entend un policier insulter une cliente
en fait il avait oublié de raccrocher
alors qu'il rappelait une femme de 34
ans qui venait de porter plainte pour
agression sexuelle vous aviez condamné
d'ailleurs cette attitude et ce soir on
a sanctionné et il est aujourd'hui
puisqu'on en parle encore avec le
directeur général de la police nationale
moi j'ai demandé qu'il soit retiré de
ces fonctions politiques qui ne soit
plus policiers alors on a on a Anna to
mazov dans le public autrise et
activiste elle est où Anna merci Anna
merci d'être là vous êtes une militante
féministe très engagée à l'origine des
hashtags Hubert Sauveur sciences sport
ou encore double peine vous avez plus de
200000 followers sur vos comptes insta
dédié à la cosmie ce qu'elle est votre
question à monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur bonsoir à tous les deux déjà
merci Madame donc je suis venue en fait
vous interpellez sur ce qu'il se passe
actuellement pour les femmes dans ce
pays et qui est évidemment on va le voir
lié à ce qui peut se passer dans les
commissariats et pas forcément la
fonction policière en elle-même mais
nous allons y venir on va reprendre des
faits tout simple à la fin des années 90
donc en 99
l'affaire des viols de
Fontenay-sous-Bois commencent une
première femme qui a été violée en
réunion et c'est de porter plainte ça
plainte n'est pas prise bien plus tard
une deuxième femme porte plainte pour
ses violents réunion en 2012 le procès a
finalement lieu et à ce moment là
là il y a un non lieu en fait sur les
sur les viols en réunion et nous avons
des victimes il y en a une qui fait une
tentative de suicide il y a une qui est
en dépression et elles ne sont même pas
capables à cause de tout ce qui s'est
passé au cours de la procédure de se
rendre au procès leur violeurs n'ont pas
été condamnés seuls quatre sur 14 des
violeurs d'une des deux femmes ont été
condamnés à de très courtes peines sur
l'ensemble sinon il n'y a pas eu de réel
peine et bien des années après en 2021
nous avons vu une vague de témoignages
réémergée sous le hashtag double peine
que j'ai porté avec des consœurs
activistes également et nous avons pu
voir que dans les commissariats de
France les plaintes n'étaient pas
toujours bien prises et
ce à quoi ça peut mener c'est que les
femmes et c'est pour ça que ce hashtag
s'appelait double peine subissent des
violences sexuelles subissent des
violences physiques et j'ai à côté de
moi une préparatrice mentale qui
travaille avec ces femmes bénévolement
au quotidien et nous avons des destins
brisés mais nous avons aussi des femmes
qui meurent nous avons parlé tout à
l'heure de sécurité très longuement et
d'attentat les féminicides en France
c'est un Bataclan par an moi ma question
monsieur est la suivante lorsque le
coronavirus est arrivé à déferlé sur le
monde et est arrivé en France nous avons
réussi l'État a réussi en tout cas à
mettre en place des plans d'urgence
lorsqu'il y a eu des attentats l'État a
réussi à déployer vigipirax et a
également mettre en place des plans
d'urgence alors ma question est la
suivante une femme est gelée toutes les
scènes minutes dans ce pays une femme
meurt sous les coups de son conjoint
tous les trois jours dans ce pays
monsieur ce sont nos petites sœurs ce
sont nos maires ce sont vos épouses ce
sont nos amis qui sont violets qui sont
battus et cela ça arrive partout on sait
que l'immense majorité des violences
sexistes surviennent dans l'entourage
proche et notamment l'entourage familial
donc il n'y a pas de couleur il n'y a
pas de classe sociale aux violences
sexistes et sexuelles cela fait des
années que les associations réclament un
milliard et réclament bon nombre de
mesures monsieur Darmanin je sais que
nous sommes pour la seconde fois au cœur
du quinquennat des droits des femmes en
tout cas c'est ce que Monsieur Macron a
annoncé monsieur Darmanin quand
comptez-vous faire face à cette urgence
pour de vrai pour que toutes ces
situations ne nous remontent plus
est-ce que vous allez je peux
est-ce que vous avez trouvé quand même
que depuis quelques années je voudrais
dire quelques mois mais depuis quelques
années Marlène vous la connaissez serait
capable d'en témoigner mieux que je ne
le peut le faire une amélioration
tournée absolument pas parfait et je
[Musique]
constate moi-même qui a 400000 plaintes
déposées et dossiers en cours
d'instruction et donc j'imagine toutes
celles qui n'ont pas été déposées donc
je veux pas dire que c'est que la
réalité des choses sur les violences
intrafamiliales donc c'est à dire que
derrière les affaires de SUP faut que
vous compreniez mais vous le savez
madame vous connaissez ces sujets très
très bien c'est le deuxième contentieux
des policiers et des gendarmes et
d'ailleurs derrière tout ça il faut
beaucoup de formations il faut beaucoup
d'officiers tous les judiciaires comme
Madame il faut aussi beaucoup de
magistrats qui suivent mais est-ce que
vous trouvez quand même pas que depuis
quelques années les choses vont mieux je
dis pas qu'elles vont parfaitement bien
je dis pas qu'il y a pas d'énormes
améliorations encore à apporter mais
est-ce que vous trouvez pas qu'on a pris
un peu conscience de ça aussi
dans les commissariats dans les brigades
de gendarmerie pour parler avec des
services de police et gendarmerie mais
j'imagine en fait que des que des
efforts ont été faits mais moi ce dont
je vous parle et vous savez que je viens
du monde civil je n'ai pas demandé je
suis pas affilié à un parti politique et
effectivement j'ai déjà pu discuter avec
Madame Marlène Chappat au sujet de la
faire uber c'est over il a quelques
années d'ailleurs mon petit qui resurgit
ces temps-ci mais ça c'est un autre
débat et moi la question c'est pourquoi
pourquoi ça a des personnes du monde
civile de recevoir cette audience de
recevoir des témoignages mais à vous
briser le coeur et moi vous savez je
suis dans la vente saine
comment vous pensez que je me sens quand
je reçois des témoignages comme ça toute
la journée
qu'est-ce qu'on pourquoi il y a pas eu
quelque chose de concret pour que ça
n'arrive plus et pour qu'il n'y ait plus
de violences sexistes et sexuelles dans
ce pays et je sais que pour certaines
pour certains comment dire dans
certaines situations d'urgence on arrive
à mettre en place des plans d'urgence je
reprends l'exemple du covid je reprends
l'exemple pourquoi je pense que alors je
comprends une question de moyens et
peut-être qu'il faudrait davantage de
moyens vous avez parfaitement raison
je sais que Marlène c'est longtemps
battu j'espère qu'elle a eu un Miss du
budget il a écouté mais peut-être pas à
la hauteur de ce que vous demandez
madame en tout cas je lis on l'a suivi
c'est vrai que Marlène Schiappa essayait
vraiment de en tout cas je trouve ça
beaucoup plus avancé ces dernières
années en tout cas sous la houlette de
Marlène shabbat que ce que que ce que ça
avançait avant je trouve après voilà de
ce que je vois moi aussi de naturel bien
sûr s'il y a encore énormément de
travail mais je trouve que Marlène a
fait quand même un travail incroyable
là-dessus après ce que dit Madame c'est
que vous savez bien aussi vous êtes
parti d'un exemple il y a quand même un
certain temps malgré tout même s'il est
extrêmement d'actualité
auparavant les services de pays séjour
gendarmerie je dis pas qu'il faisait
aucune aucun effort il y a toujours eu
des efforts qui ont été faits mais enfin
ils prenaient moins au sérieux
non seulement les violences physiques ou
les agressions sexuelles mais aussi des
violences psychologiques parce que c'est
un autre domaine encore voilà désormais
je dis pas que c'est parfait dans tous
les commissariats de France mais je peux
vous assurer que tous les gardiens de la
paix qui sont à l'école désormais sont
formés à cela d'ailleurs c'est des
associations qui interviennent c'est pas
les policiers eux-mêmes que nous avons
formé les deux tiers des policiers et
des gendarmes aujourd'hui il reste
encore un gros tiers à former c'est bien
vrai et que nous avons même dans la loi
changer un centre de choses moi j'ai été
interpellé par des avocats que nous
avons reçu derrière avec Marlène un
ministère de l'Intérieur qui disait que
souvent les services de police
refusaient le droit d'aller avec leur
plaignantes
lorsqu'il est déposé plainte parce que
vous avez le droit à votre avocat
évidemment lorsque vous êtes accusé mais
que tous les Français sachent qu'un
policier n'a pas le droit de refuser
votre plainte
et que oui il n'a pas le droit de
refuser que vous soyez accompagné de
quelqu'un majeur et donc totalement d'un
avocat et j'ai moi-même fait modifier il
y a un an vous le savez la loi pour
rendre obligatoire le fait que le
policier et le gendarme ne pouvait en
aucun cas même pour l'exécuter des
locaux refuser qu'il y a un avocat ce
qui permet des repositions
déplacées comme vous l'avez vous même
dénoncer madame que il puisse y avoir un
tiers caisson d'avocat et c'est tout à
fait normal on n'a rien à cacher dans la
police nationale gendarmerie
deuxièmement il y a le fait de venir
dans un commissariat brigade de
gendarmerie c'est pas un endroit très
sympathique un commissariat c'est
souvent un peu triste il y a des
difficultés il y a plein de misères et
puis on vient pas parler de son problème
d'agression c'est très difficile bon
donc on essaie d'améliorer l'accueil
mais c'est très difficile ce qu'on a
fait depuis le début de cette année
c'est qu'on a expérimenté dans 10
départements et on va le généraliser
l'année prochaine donc ça ça demande
beaucoup de moyens et dans les 15
milliards vous savez madame il y a 900
millions d'euros pour la police la
gendarmerie on n'est pas loin du
meilleur que vous évoquez pour améliorer
pour les violences intrafamiliales les
moyens des policiers et des gendarmes
début de réponse c'est important oui
alors ça sera peut-être encore passé
parce que évidemment il y a de plus en
plus de cas parce que la parole se
libère mais moi je vous dis je vais
essayer de faire moi je suis tout à fait
prêt à m'endors sous forme de choses
notamment pour que les policiers
gendarmes aille chez vous dans votre
association chez votre avocat au CCAS de
la commune n'importe où vous avez pris
l'exemple du covid vous voyez comme on
fait du aller vers et maintenant ils ont
les moyens avec leur ordinateurs de
prendre votre plainte là où vous sentez
le mieux possible y compris dans une
association qui défend le droit des
femmes premièrement deuxièmement on va
faire à partir de l'année prochaine la
plainte en ligne vous ne pouvez pas
faire des plaintes en ligne vous êtes
obligé de vous déplacer l'année
prochaine vous pourrez mettre votre
plainte avec vos coordonnées pour
pouvoir laisser un policier vous
rappeler ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui puisque pour plein de
raisons il y a un blocage parfois pour
aller voir un policier agenda parce
qu'on a peur d'être mal reçu peut-être
si parce qu'on n'a pas envie d'en parler
et qu'on préfère l'écrit nous allons
aussi mettre en place la loi que je
porte la plainte en visio donc la
personne qui peut pas se déplacer qui
est qui est prostrée qui est pas
accompagné puisse se faire aussi en
visio avec l'identité numérique on
essaie de débloquer la parole après sur
les les féminicides madame si je prends
l'exemple de de l'année 2021 et je crois
qu'il y a eu 135 parce que vous disiez
un Bataclan donc 130 personnes parce que
une petite partie d'homme mais 130
personnes qui sont qui ont été tués par
les coûts de leur conjoint il y en a
vous le savez bien qu'un tiers qu'on
fait des
signalements à la police sur la justice
c'est un tiers de trop on a beaucoup
amélioré mais il y en a quand même de
tiers qui n'ont jamais interpellé un
service de police gendarmerie alors pour
deux raisons soit parce que ils n'ont
pas confiance dans la police et de la
gendarmerie et qu'il faut qu'on améliore
notre notre process et on découvre en
même temps si j'ose dire l'immense
continent caché qui était les violences
entre la familiales vous savez bien il y
a des moi j'ai des exemples y compris
familiaux ou jamais quelqu'un de ma
famille n'aurait déposé plainte pour une
claque qui a été mise aujourd'hui et
c'est très bien on le fait donc il y a
effectivement cette masse de personnes à
recevoir et c'est le travail et la force
de la police que d'essayer de le faire
dans des conditions difficiles parce que
la dame qui est derrière pour vous dire
aussi que quand quelqu'un rate une
procédure moi je le sanctionne à
Mérignac par exemple
quand les policiers n'ont pas bien fait
leur travail pour plein de raisons j'ai
viré tout le monde j'ai viré le policier
j'ai viré le commissaire j'ai viré le
directeur départemental donc on a des
moyens à donner aussi au service de
police il y a dans les vous savez qu'il
y a des policiers et des policiers qui
font un travail admirable
d'accompagnement aussi mais encore une
fois ça j'aimerais est-ce que je peux
juste en fait il y a juste un truc c'est
que très souvent quand en tant que
personne féministe assez médiatisé on
peut apporter des des propos en fait qui
sont importants pour toutes les femmes
de ce pays sur la table et sur la table
disons publics on nous fait souvent le
procès de la féministe hystérique alors
le féminisme c'est juste vouloir une
égalité réelle dans le droit donc ça
doit vraiment dans les textes mais aussi
dans dans les faits dans la rue dans nos
foyers enfin partout une vraie égalité
et on nous là en l'occurrence on nous a
fait un procès de l'antipolis moi j'ai
quand même fini avec des communiqués de
syndicats policiers sur le dos alors
qu'en fait et j'ai dû venir établir la
vérité monsieur je sais parfois les
syndicats de police qui m'attaque aussi
je moi ce que je veux juste c'est que
les femmes de ce pays pour qu'ils
puissent avoir une réelle justice n'est
plus jamais peur de franchir la porte
d'un commissariat et pour cela quand il
y a des mauvais éléments et des gens qui
ne font pas le travail pour lequel ils
sont payés ces personnes-là soient
réellement sanctionnelles
je pense que vous avez vu le site double
peine.fr qui répertorier qui
cartographie tous les mauvais tous les
mauvais accueils malheureusement
je pense que déjà ça ça va c'est c'est
de bonne piste il y a deux choses parce
que il y a effectivement la sœur d'aller
dans un commissariat de Jean-Louis il y
a aussi plein de fées qui sont pas ceux
de la police qui mériteraient d'être
porté à la connaissance de la police je
sais qu'un secret médical je sais que
les médecins sont très jaloux de ce
secret médical et je le respecte enfin
on l'a levé ce secret médical quand il y
a des violences sur les mineurs vous
savez quand il y a un viol sur un enfant
de moins de 15 ans le médecin est obligé
de dénoncer on a eu des balles lors de
la confession au moment de l'Église
catholique la question autour du rapport
qui avait été rendu et tout le monde a
été choqué je crois qu'on puisse pas
dénoncer cela malgré le secret de la
confession il y a peut-être pour les
femmes de violence de violence aussi à
délier une partie du secret médical moi
c'est ma proposition je sais qu'elle
fait pas consensus pour qu'elle puisse
pour qu'elle puisse saisir les services
de police quand un médecin constate que
quelqu'un une femme a été tapée parce
qu'elle demande un arrêt de travail ou
qu'elle a connu des ressources sexuelles
y compris dans le coup parce qu'il y a
beaucoup d'agressions sexuels dans le
couple qui est très compliqué évidemment
à à
extérioriser à apporter sur la place
publique à portée policier je pense que
si les médecins on arriverait à trouver
un moyen de mieux travailler avec eux
pour connaître sa formation pour
intervenir plus en amont et peut-être
que madame qui est OPJ derrière parce
que vous étiez au PJ voilà elle doit
faire elle a dû faire où elle sait des
enquêtes et peut-être vous expliquer la
difficulté de son métier aussi alors si
vous permettez oui oui donc en fait j'ai
travaillé à l'abri des gars de
protection de la famille pendant 8 ans
spécialisée qui s'occupe des femmes et
les enfants pour faire vite de la
protection de la famille donc
effectivement des femmes battues j'en ai
malheureusement rencontré énormément
comme le dit monsieur le ministre c'est
vrai à une certaine époque on n'était
pas formé à ça aujourd'hui on a des
formations qui sont faites avec un
canevas tout prêt parce que bon vous
avez des gens de chez nous qui prennent
des plaintes mais ce n'est pas leur
métier à la base ils sont pas dans
l'investigation donc pour eux c'est
compliqué parce que il y a une certaine
psychologie à avoir effectivement il y a
donc il nous a été donné un canevas bien
établi pour pouvoir justement
pouvoir poser les bonnes questions et
pouvoir apporter une réponse voilà plus
positive
là par contre si vous me permettez
Monsieur le Ministre
j'ai été extrêmement choquée par une
certaine formation justement sur les
violences conjugales qui a été qui nous
demandait d'être faite mais en ligne
c'est-à-dire que on n'a jamais eu en
face de nous une personne qui est venue
alors peut-être quelqu'un d'une
association etc
le site internet de la police nationale
et on a eu l'impression alors comme
beaucoup comme la formation sur les
suicides aussi ça alors là ça moi je
vous en donne énormément mon ami face à
merci parce que on a l'impression si
vous voulez que vous ouvrez le parapluie
excusez moi je me permets vous m'avez
dit que je serais pas
contrairement à madame je suis pas être
un dictateur avec mes forces de police
vous ne seriez pas viré ce qui est
policière donc on a l'impression
monsieur le ministre que vous ouvrez le
parapluie bon c'est bon on leur donne
cette formation à faire on les oblige à
la faire par internet c'est bon pour la
formation continue quand vous êtes déjà
policier sorti d'école c'est ça oui oui
pour la formation continue oui oui tout
à fait et notamment cette formation sur
les femmes battues sur les femmes
battues elle était faite en ligne et
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué ensuite
pour vous répondre madame
moi j'ai
vous faites un travail remarquable
toutefois néanmoins
combien de fois et ça peut-être que vous
pourrez me l'expliquer parce que
personne peut me l'expliquer pourquoi
est-ce que quand on intervient chez une
femme qui a été battue qu'on intervient
qu'on veut l'aider et qui au bout d'un
moment s'en prend soit à nous
quand on veut l'interpeller son mari
parce que ça m'est arrivé c'est pour ça
que je me permets de vous le dire soit
on s'en prend à nous encore une fois non
mais laissez-le mais en fait il est pas
si méchant que ça non mais c'est pas
grave du coup la formation a pas lieu
d'être bien faite je regrette parce que
vous pourrez me contredire mais si je
veux dire mais c'est l'emprise on a je
crois que les associations et les
psychologues spécialisés ont démontré
que en moyenne une femme revient sept
fois voilà et il y a une emprise qui à
la fois il me fait beaucoup de mal et en
même temps je suis sous son emprise
c'est pour ça que il faut pas simplement
définir les violences physiques mais
également les violences psychologiques
et pour ça faut très bien former des
policiers ce qu'on n'a pas encore
totalement réussi à faire entièrement
d'accord merci Vanessa en tout cas merci
Monsieur ministre d'avoir répondu cette
question et merci Anna
qui accompagne qui accompagnait des
victimes dans les différentes affaires
que j'ai portées qui est experte en la
matière
en fait c'est qu'il y a des phénomènes
d'emprise
bien souvent avant la violence physique
arrive la violence psychologique on
enferme les gens mentalement voilà
pourquoi ils s'en prennent
aux personnes qui viennent dans cette
bulle là voilà c'est pour ça aussi qu'il
faut former les policiers à ça c'est
tout ce que j'avais merci merci
je peux comprendre que des gens se
disent on en fait passer parce que il y
a des féminicides peut-être pas tous les
jours mais évidemment beaucoup et c'est
toujours un drame d'abord moi je suis
pour ce qu'annoncer la première ministre
par nature évidemment mais je pense que
je suis très convaincu de ça des
tribunaux spécialisés comme il y en a en
Espagne en Espagne ils ont réussi à
juguler une partie pas toutes des
violences intrafamiliales en
spécialisant les magistrats les
tribunaux et donc les services
enquêteurs maintenant la première liste
a annoncé on va le faire ça c'est une
révolution parce que aujourd'hui
l'accusé de violence conjugale il se
présente un peu comme les autres avec
d'autres personnes et donc il faut
spécialiser le magistrat spécialisé
enquêteur ça ça va être je crois une
révolution et ça marche en Espagne et
par exemple ça marche pas deuxièmement
vous êtes dans le débat parlementaire
qu'on a eu au Sénat et un sénateur la
pierre jean-vergelaine qui est là
notamment d'emprise il y avait une
question qui a fait rire par parfois les
sénateurs mais mais beaucoup ont trouvé
ça sérieux et je sais que c'est sérieux
pour l'avoir vécu dans ma mairie quand
j'ai eu ce genre de constat à faire avec
les services de police par exemple
l'emprise sur les animaux ou sur le
logement ou sur les enfants du genre ne
va pas dénoncer ou fais-moi ça parce que
j'ai ton chat bon voilà et je pense que
ça c'est des choses ça peut faire rire
comme ça mais il y a plein de de
phénomènes ça peut être les enfants ça
peut être le logement moi j'ai connu des
assistantes maternelles qui vivaient
dans leur appartement qui était battu
par leur mari et qui n'osait pas
dénoncer leur mari parce qu'ils allaient
perdre leur boulot parce que s'il
partait de chez eux bah ils partaient et
ils perdait leur agrément du conseil
départemental et leurs gamins donc il y
a plein de choses il y a pas question de
service de police il y a évidemment les
services de police mais il y a comment
les maires trouvent des logements
alternatifs comment par exemple madame
non mais il y a peut-être sans doute
plus qu'à me dire mais un autre exemple
madame vous ne pouvez pas demander un
logement social en France si vous êtes
propriétaire
la première chose que fait un élu quand
il reçoit quelqu'un il dit bah voilà on
va vous trouver un autre logement mais
je peux pas parce que je suis
propriétaire avec mon mari mais mon mari
me battre j'ai porté plainte contre lui
donc il faut divorcer donc il fait du
chantage au divorce donc il fait traîner
et pendant ce temps-là on n'a pas changé
nous la loi ça c'est une erreur qu'on
est faite pour trouver un logement même
quand on est propriétaire en tout cas il
y a plein de choses à faire je ne dis
pas le contraire j'essaie de vous
convaincre quand ce qui nous concerne on
essaie d'améliorer les choses on
découvre tous les jours et moi je suis
tout à fait alors il y a Sonia bac S qui
est là aussi je suis à votre disposition
pour continuer à travailler il faut il
faut vraiment faire mieux il y a urgence
si téléspectateur qui nous suit depuis
le début de l'émission doivent se dire
il y a du boulot quand même
pour ça